neurologist ted florendo who is inside
and away from the heat
he's talking about more about this uh
triple digit uh weather that we're
having right
yeah christian great advice though we
appreciate that too also check your
coolant guys you gotta do that this time
of year because
you have it uh in the spring months and
now it's going to be draining pretty
quickly live look outside right now
nice day but it is hot out there that's
our tower cam looking towards the east
new update to show you here right 107
our official high for the day today
means we tied the record set back in
2003. we knew we were going to come
tie the record or at least break it 107
are high
and anytime we reach 100 degrees or more
our good friends at silver state
refrigeration and hvac will donate
hundred dollars to two local charities
that represents vets and pets we thank
you so much i think we're three hundred
dollars right now
and the heat's going to continue 110
centennial hills at this hour
similar 100 even these are your current
numbers outside 104 for aliante 108
downtown in north las vegas
the east side coming in also at 108
green valley included 104 seven hills
henderson 105 rhodes ranch and mountains
edge 103
southern highlands at 108 degrees as
well 104 for prompt
boulder city checking in 106. it's hot
out in inyo county death valley you're
scorching at 114
and 109 currently for lofland and this
goes not just here
all across the west coast look at
portland 90 degrees 84 in seattle look
at boise 94 degrees
salt lake even checking in right now at
90 degrees the cool sector of course
is way out where brian lives used to
live 73 degrees
out there nice and comfortable 68 out
there in the mid-atlantic states high
pressure
in charge that's the reason for all the
heat here and that's going to be around
for the next few days here
with this over us on top of us to the
north that means the numbers are still
going to stay
hot here are the records 107 today we
tied that
107 tomorrow we're probably going to tie
that or beat that but we won't reach the
record
on friday at least not right now we
could come close to that or even tie
that
but then we'll get out of record
territory on saturday and sunday as
those numbers start to drop
81 overnight mostly clear and warm light
winds 107 for tomorrow
again near record heat many of our
neighborhoods tomorrow look at this
105 for centennial hills 105 also
mountains edge
106 north las vegas 105 all the way out
there in henderson you'll be hot there
104 for prompt and 105 also for
boulder city 120 for death valley
tomorrow afternoon here's your
eight day setup here heat warning
through friday your numbers start to
drop
saturday and sunday and look at next
week we told you we get a little bit of
relief but
really high 90s not much relief but we
will take it
and we'll be back in the century mark on
thursday that is your most
accurate forecast